No. I started the race to run for Congress.
And part of that reason was because Maxine waters trying to get help with my VA
benefits. Um, I was sleeping outside the lighthouse of renter's promise Virtus,
and I was going to her office every other day, trying to get help.
I filled out job applications, internships.
I even bought her flowers and I was met with silence.
And that really made me upset because the majority of the people who live on the
streets are homeless veterans and they ain't 60% of them are black.
And so you have this lady who says, well, I'm pro black,
this pro black that I fight for black people, all of this stuff.
And here I am a young black man and you're not fighting for me.
We have 44,000 homeless people in the streets.
60% of them are black veterans. You're not fighting for those people. So which,
which black people are you fighting for?
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report.
We're doing a mini interview today with Joe Collins.
Joe is a us Navy veteran and a Republican running for Congress in Los Angeles,
his 43rd district, looking to unseat Maxine waters.
Who's been in Congress for a cool 44 years.
I caught wind to Joe after his viral campaign ad that I'm sure many of you have
seen. So we're going to show you just a bite of that and then get right to the
interview with Joe. Here we go.
I'm Joe Collins. I'm running for Congress against Maxine waters.
Do you know where I am right now?
Maxine waters is $6 million matching.
Do you know where I'm not right now? Maxine waters district. Yup. That's right.
Maxine does not live in our district, but I do.
I was born right here in South LA and the place Maxine refuses to live.
Maxine waters does not drink our water. She does not breathe our air.
And while she sits here and her mansion, our district is in ruins.
Let me show you.
This is South LA. I was born here. I grew up on 140.
Normally Maxine waters has been in office for 44 years.
Has anything got better around here?
I can tell you firsthand that it hasn't ossified the drive by shooting and this
house when I was a child gangs, drugs, violence.
That was my upbringing. And where was Maxine waters? Nowhere to be found,
Joe, how's it going today? Good. How are you?
I'm doing well. I'm doing well. So look, you put that,
that add up and much like the Kim classic attic caught fire,
uh, are our new people heading your way?
Do you feel like you have some momentum right now?
Oh yeah. Um, you know, uh, success leaves clues,
and we saw what Kim did and we absolutely, you know, you know,
did one of our own and people have been coming our way for a very long time.
We'll be getting a lot of support.
But I think one of the biggest things is we had to actually shine a light on how
Maxine is compared to how we live in a district.
And we absolutely nailed it with that.
Yeah. All right. So before we, to a little bit, a little of your history,
which is pretty amazing, and you've done some great stuff,
let's talk about Maxine waters because in the ad you talk about the fact that
she lives in a $6 million mansion.
That is not in that district. If I'm not mistaken, she's in Hancock park,
which is a pretty swanky swanky area of LA,
obviously not South central. Uh,
but that she's also been in business and by business,
I mean government for 44 years,
how did she get a $6 million mansion,
which I don't begrudge someone earning money, honestly,
but in 44 years of public service,
you usually don't think of someone getting a $6 million mansion.
Yeah. You know, she has a ton of mansions. And, um, from doing research,
I've seen a lot of backhanded things that she's been doing, you know,
pocket pads and all that other type of stuff. And, uh, we have to say, you know,
it has to be corruption.
She's been labeled the most corrupt politician five times by the citizens where
ethics committee, she has a,
she has her own page and the judicial watch, uh, called career corruption.
And, uh, it features Maxine waters and everything she's been doing.
She's gotten a lot of backend deal. She's even,
she's even ripped off politicians. Um, here in California, she put,
they pay her $45,000 for an endorsement and another, you know, 10,
15, $20,000 to get on her slate, Merlot scheme that she, I was going. So,
I mean, when it comes to the corruption of,
of Maxine waters that knows no limit. Yeah.
So, all right. I don't want to get too lost on Maxine. Cause I think your,
your feelings about her are clear and I have a feeling most of my audience
probably agrees with you, but,
but let's talk about you because I don't think most people think that wait,
a black Republican from South central could, that could, that possibly exist.
Now we know a lot of stereotypes are being broken these days,
but can you tell me a little bit about your history?
So yeah, I'm from South central Los Angeles. I was born and raised there and,
uh, we ended up having to move to Texas, um,
after my house was shot up at a drive-by. So I was already in high school.
So I ended up finishing high school in Texas. I graduated in 2003,
joined the Navy in 2004. That's where I became a Republican.
And the reason why is because in the history of, um, of black people,
we see that the first black man to get involved in politics were Republicans.
And that's what the Republican party stood for. Freedom. Uh,
antislavery fight for your rights. And that's what resonated with me.
So what possessed you to possibly go into politics or cut your
comeback after the Navy? Uh, and what, what possessed you to say, all right,
I'm going to throw my hat in the ring.
I actually got out the military to get involved in politics. I take a, uh,
I got an administrative separation general under honorable conditions,
so I can still career in politics. And it was because, uh,
through the 2016 election, the voice of the younger people were not being heard.
And everybody called this lazy millennials, they called us lazy.
They said we were worthless. We couldn't do anything. And,
and mind you in the Navy and the entire military in itself,
it's about 4 million millennials that wake up every day at four o'clock in the
morning, we do more between four and eight than most people do all day.
And so whenever we would bring our issues to the table, they'll say, wait,
or it's not your turn yet, or we're going to take care of it for you,
but our voice was never heard. And so I wanted our voice to be heard.
So I got out the military, hop into politics.
I actually started off as a presidential candidate. And, um, you know,
after I learned a lot, because you know,
you can't get involved in politics in the military.
So I learned a lot as a presidential candidate. Then I started third,
the race to run for Congress.
And part of that reason was because of Maxine waters,
trying to get help with my VA benefits. Um,
I was sleeping outside the lighthouse of renter's probably Virtus and I was
going to her office every other day, trying to get help.
I filled out job applications, internships, like, and bought her flowers.
And I was met with silence.
And that really made me upset because the majority of the people who live on the
streets are homeless veterans and they ain't 60% of them are black.
And so you have this lady who says, well, I'm pro black,
this pro black that I fight for black people, all of this stuff.
And here I am a young black man and you're not fighting for me.
We have 44,000 homeless people in the streets.
60% of them are black veterans. You're not fighting for those people. So which,
which black people are you fighting for? You know? And so she has to,
she got her, she got to go.
Yeah. So why is it, you know, I'm in LA as well.
And why is it,
do you think that people in LA and really California as a whole,
but I think LA and San Francisco specifically seem unable to connect the dots
between always voting in Democrats and things always getting
worse. They seem to not be able to realize, Oh,
we keep doing the same thing and things keep going the wrong direction.
Maybe we got to vote in some other people. Have you figured out why that is?
I think it's because when it,
when it comes to politics and this is something that I've noticed, um, you know,
a lot of candidates don't run to when they want to be famous,
they wouldn't be social media influencers.
So they don't put in the necessary work that it takes to, um, to win a campaign,
to, to raise money, to get their messages out.
And so that's what we've been seeing for a very long time. People want change,
but if they don't know you exist, they can't vote for you.
Yeah. So, so what are the things that you want to do? I mean,
we all know the homeless situation in LA is, is just,
it almost seems like every week it gets worse. What are some of like the heart,
give me like three, four of just the,
the linchpin things that you want to accomplish and how you're going to do it.
Okay. Well,
I have my five point plan and the reason why I came to Chicago with all five,
let's do it. All right.
So I want to rebuild the infrastructure to support the expansion of, uh,
small businesses, as well as housing. Um,
I want to overhaul the education and start rebuilding our high schools in the
43rd district. I want to bring quality jobs back, um,
improve the relationship between the law enforcement and the community.
And I also want to bring financial literacy back. And these are just basics,
basic things that you need in order to have a productive, positive society.
So we have to get back to the basics and, you know, you asked, how am I do it?
It's, it's easy. You just go to work and you do your job.
And I know that on a private capacity, what we've been able to do, um,
with the campaign I've been able to do in the community, uh,
as far as bringing jobs and taking care of our community COVID-19 is absolutely
possible. And it's easy. You just have to want to do it.
Yeah. Let's talk about the policing situation,
because obviously everyone's talking about that all the time. Uh,
w w what do you make about the relations between the police and I hate phrases
like the black community, but, you know,
with at least the constituents in your district right now.
It's kind of tough because everybody overemphasizes the, um,
the issues of police brutality and inner cities,
and they ignore everything else that we have going on in our communities.
And a lot of times, um, you know, when you hear,
or a black person was shot by a cop, it has to be racism.
Even though the cop was either black or the cop was Latino, um,
who shot the guy? Uh, it has to be racist for some point.
And then they always point out, well, cops did this,
and cops did that all the time.
And having someone like Maxine waters coming to the community,
doesn't make it easy.
Having organizations like black lives matter coming into the community,
doesn't make it any easy because, you know,
if we have such an issue with police,
then what we need to be working on is police reform.
We need to get social training within our police departments.
We need to get better oversight committees within our police department.
We need to increase the budget so we can have better training for our police
department. And these are things that people are bringing to the table,
but these are things that I've been able to work with. Um, the mayor on,
and we've been doing a really good job.
So we've been standing in the gap between the,
the police department and the community, making sure things they come.
And a lot of people from the, you know, black lives matter organization,
don't like it because they raised money off hatred and fear.
But at the end of the day,
when it comes to taking responsibility for the community,
this is something that, you know, me and my team has done has been.
Yeah. So I'm not a huge fan of Eric, our city,
our mayor here in LA. Can you want to try to sell me on him a little bit?
Or is this just one thing you've been able to work with him on.
No, I'm not going to sell anybody on, on mayor Garcetti,
cause he's never sold anybody on me.
But I think when you're in a leadership position,
it is your obligation to work with the people who are leaders in order to affect
better change.
And I don't have a problem with working with anybody if it's going to create
some type of positive change. Um, do I like him personally? Maybe he's a,
he's a us Navy sailor. Do I like his policies? You know, sometimes I do,
sometimes I don't, but at the end of the day, if we could take some,
some type of, uh, some type of medium ground to,
to build some type of relationships to improve our communities, I'm with it.
Yeah. So backing up for just a sec,
w when you hear people talk about defunding the police and everything else,
I've heard, a lot of people basically say, this is just like a media construct.
Like nobody really wants it done. Is that what you're hearing from?
Um, nobody's going to defy the police department. I mean,
when you look at the amount of gang violence and gun violence,
domestic violence and drugs and alcohol related incidents, and, and, um,
you know, all these cases in our communities,
you absolutely don't want to defund the police.
The crazy part about it is the same people who talk about defunding police are
the same people who call the police. Something happens to him, you know,
so it's never going to happen.
It's like a red hair and it's the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my entire
life.
Yeah. W what do you make about just the,
the general state of politics right now? Not just your district,
not just Maxine waters, but like what's happening nationally. Trump Biden, the,
the, the over an intense focus on politics all day long. What do you think?
I, I think it's a mess.
I think this is the complete reason why we need term limits.
We have politicians who refused to work together. Everybody want to be right,
but they're trying to implement the same things that they had in the seventies
and eighties. It didn't work, then it's not going to work now.
And we have a president who's struggling trying to get things done for our
country. And, you know, people just don't want to work together. So, uh,
we got to get these people out of office and went on every single level.
At some point,
these politicians should have been aged out and created an Avenue for new,
a younger politicians with fresh ideas.
Yeah. All right. Well, listen, I wish we had more time, but, uh,
we did this one on the fly just cause I saw the ad and I want it to help get the
word out.
I hope to see you in real life in LA your neighborhood or mine is fine with me,
uh, for people that want to follow you and, and,
and help you before election time, where can they go?
My website is Joe Collins for congress.com.
You can find me on Facebook and Instagram at Collins for Congress four, three.
And you can find me at Twitter or at Joe Collins. 43rd. Okay.
Yo, you got to hook me up with the guy who did that video.
Cause I need some slick branding like that, man.
All right. I got you. I got you. All right. Thanks a lot, Joe. Alright.
Talk to you later.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.